well the golden knights are holding a
full-blown scrimmage tonight at t-mobile
arena
but held an abbreviated practice earlier
today sports director chris matthews
here with more on today's development
chris
well thank you christian you had to give
the team a real feel for how far they
have to come and how those preparations
are going
for the upcoming season the team will
hold a scrimmage this evening boy it's
been a long time too long really since
the team has suited up over at their
home ice arena so they'll jump on the
ice tonight media not invited but we'll
see if
they provide any highlights for us or
anything but earlier today city national
boy not much going on there short
practice not more than really much of a
skate around but tonight these guys will
treat the scrimmage like a full-blown
game
which will be important since the season
starts one week from tonight
two players who were out there on the
ice today their top goalies robin
leonard and
mark andre fleury both these guys will
be counted on big time this season
you know being able to have you know two
number one guys is huge
um you know we have faith in both of
them and um you know we know at times
they can both stand on their heads and
um you know hopefully they're not gonna
have to work too hard
um you know with our with our decor in
the way that we're playing but
it's definitely a
[Music]
i blessing to be better than i was last
year um i was not happy with
the amount of uh goals that i scored so
hopefully
um or not hopefully i will be better
this year so um that's that's one of my
goals
all right so once again if we get
anything from tonight's scrimmage we'll
certainly
show you this evening at 11 o'clock one
week from tonight vegas hosting the
anaheim ducks at t-mobile seven o'clock